es ist eine klinik des grauens im
bergmann klinikum in potsdam wurde wohl
ziemlich viel falsch gemacht was dem
krankenhaus den namen kobe 19 klinik
eingebracht hat das robert koch institut
hat die klinik inzwischen inspiziert und
das ergebnis ist katastrophal wie
ausgerechnet eine klinik zur todesfalle
werden kann klicks und science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen potsdam
die hauptstadt von brandenburg in der
nähe von berlin wird inzwischen als
super cluster bezeichnet und das liegt
vor allem an einem krankenhaus im
klinikum ernst von bergmann sind nach
jetzigem stand inzwischen 29 menschen an
cholera gestorben und der verdacht liegt
nahe dass sich zahlreiche opfer erst in
klinikum angesteckt haben nach dem
dramatischen verlauf dort wurde das
robert-koch-institut um hilfe gerufen
die katastrophale situation zu
untersuchen und das ergebnis des
internen prüfberichts ist ernüchternd so
berichten die potsdamer neueste
nachrichten demnach besteht der verdacht
dass die klinik mit ihrem handeln alles
nur noch schlimmer gemacht hat am 27
märz entdeckte klinik einen massiven
corona ausbruch in der geriatrie also im
bereich der alten medizin mit 33
infizierten und das erst nachdem sie die
patienten auf bewohner getestet hatten
die kobik 19 erkrankten waren offenbar
vorher gar nicht aufgefallen
was danach folgte muss wohl eine
panikreaktion gewesen seien ganz
abteilungen wurden verlegt patientinnen
und patienten und das mit katastrophalen
folgen laut robert-koch-institut kurz rk
ii durch die nach bekanntwerden des
nosokomialen ausbruchsgeschehens damit
sind krankenhausinfektionen gemeint
erfolgten mehrfachen umzügen ganze
stationen und bereiche mit zahlreichen
zu diesem zeitpunkt bekannten und noch
nicht bekannten comic 19 patientinnen
und patienten kann es zu weiteren
übertragungen gekommen seien und weiter
auch ist die aufbereitung von ganzen
stationen sehr aufwendig und kaum ohne
große wahrscheinlichkeit von weiteren
übertragungen durch die umwelt möglich
satz kopf zwei überlebt wahrscheinlich
mehr als 72 stunden auf toter materie
man kann es kaum glauben während in ganz
deutschland kontakt verbote galten
wurden im klinikum offenbar patientinnen
und patienten nach lust und laune durch
die gegend geschoben und das hat
die beschriebenen dramatischen folgen
und bis heute gibt es noch keine
entwarnung denn das chaos hält scheinbar
an das rk ii kritisiert in seinem
prüfbericht laut potsdamer neuesten
nachrichten dass noch niemand einen
genauen überblick habe wohin wann welche
patienten bewegt worden sind infizierte
und nicht infizierte ganz konkret
herrscht laut drk absolutes chaos so
muss man wohl die forderung des
instituts interpretieren demnach müsse
das krankenhaus eine line list und
zeitschiene führen da sonst kein
überblick über das geschehen gewonnen
werden kann
dazu gehörten unter anderem die angaben
zu zeit ort und personen personal und
patientinnen und patienten aufnahmedatum
station datum verlegung auf andere
stationen kontaktpersonen status sowie
bei infizierten erkenntnisse zur
herkunft der saas kopf zwei infektionen
und dokumentation der behandlung
außerdem müsse es eine strukturierte
testung und nachvollziehbare
dokumentation sowie zusammenführung der
laborbefunde für das personal geben und
als wäre das nicht schlimm genug das
klinikum hat laut der potsdamer
amtsärztin christina böhm auch die
infektionen viel zu spät gemeldet laut
infektionsschutzgesetz hat die meldung
innerhalb von 24 stunden zu erfolgen die
amtsärztin moniert dass die meldung des
klinikums 14 tage lang unvollständig
waren jetzt mit den nachmeldungen ist
potsdam mit seiner inzidenz also der
anzahl der erkrankten pro 100000
einwohner auf einem spitzenplatz in
deutschland mit 260 nur bayern hat mit
268 mehr infizierte pro monat 1000 weil
dort die zahlreichen ischgl rückkehrer
saß kopf zwei verbreitet haben und die
konsequenzen sind bitter dass bergmann
klinikum kann keinen neuen infiziert
mehr aufnehmen und auch das zweite
krankenhaus in potsdam ist jetzt schon
überlastet und hat die aufnahme gestoppt
das st josefs krankenhaus das geschehen
dokumentiert auf dramatische weise wie
schnell die infektion aus dem ruder
laufen kann und dass eben unser
gesundheitssystem dann überlastet wird
und alle leute lügen straft die die
infektion verharmlosen corona virus
antikörper test wie hoch ist die
dunkelziffer sehr spannende frage die
ein fach medizin beantwortet also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
ein fach medizin macht wirklich sehr
sehr gute und fundierte videos und
regelmäßig live updates also unbedingt
abonnieren hier draufklicken und
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran